okay the boys have Hedley are kicking
off their cage loose two or thirty two
stops across the country ending March
23rd in Kelowna BC but tonight the guys
opened up to me and told me what it
really feels like to open up your home
what does it feel like to be back on
tour again
oh man it's kind of like finally
scratching an inch you know I think what
we do is so constant whether we're
writing or recording or or playing and
touring it's kind of always one or the
other and so we'll get into these big
modes after chewing for quite a while
we'll be like okay time to get off the
road time to just start getting creative
again and make an album and stay in the
studio and that becomes like this like
world you live in for a while just like
touring and then after a stretch we're
all kind of like okay let's get out bats
and they're all yeah kind of get really
hyped about that and so these the final
days it's always this thing that we go
through which we get to share with Benny
now for the first time that's right
we're we're like here we go again
[Music]
yes it's Headley's seventh studio album
cageless that sees the boys hitting the
road again but this time they have new
member j.bennison officially joining
them on stage what does it feel like for
you I mean it's awesome yeah
what's the one thing that you don't miss
doing when you're out on the road
whether it's laundry the grocery haul
what is the one thing you're like yeah
I'm ready to say goodbye to that but I'm
cool to get away from traffic for a
while you're like see you later yeah I
don't miss laundry I do this thing where
when I come home I'm so used to like
being in hotels for so long that there's
like a trail of my stuff wherever I go
like the shower towel turns into the
clothes I was wearing in this because in
a hotel you'll like leave and then come
back the next morning and everything is
just like clean or that night nobody's
right used to that so I get used to that
so who's the messiest on tour don't mean
to take everybody you guys can be honest
I don't I don't want to point any
fingers I don't care okay I just I
forget about where my stuff is
who's the cleanest on tour them well I'm
fairly clean but my toiletry bag could
be a bag of health sometimes so I don't
know how I've got through my life like
that and did you decide what you're all
going to wear for the tour or someone
help you with that we decided actually
just recently we kind of put that all
together yeah and that's a big part of
it too because that really adds to the
show for us it's how we want to come out
on stage it's how we want it to show to
sort of transition into other elements
and other vibes and how we wanted to
conclude and all those elements you know
it's fun to let you know what we're
wearing kind of do the talking and it it
and I think for us it's not so much
about that it has to be that it's got to
be so many different things but it's for
us that it's it's that we care enough
about it that it's got to be something
rock that bit